I have another thing I found on an
Instagram comment which I found
particularly amusing and I have to bring
it up what okay so this guy wrote you he
says Bobby Lee
Rhonda Rousey and me are huge fans but
your comments about her coach in Toronto
were out of line we love your comedy but
you should stay away from fight strategy
because it was disrespectful me and
Rhonda and Ed are looking forward to
attending your life podcast but an
apology would be great to fix the issue
because okay and so I was like this
Marcin is not real good but I run to
follow them they're friends he's part of
the camp but I also don't believe like
for I in my opinion I'm sorry no I'm
sorry no don't be sorry your opinions
are your opinions right my thing is
that's not a good look for her I think
she would be perturbed that a friend of
hers would write that yeah I don't think
that she would cosign with that with
with that at all
your you know it's uh she is a
revolutionary kind of a person without
her there would be no women's MMA and
she is a legend and also I think here's
what I always think like you can have a
lot of fighters say oh you know she
wasn't a good sport or we know exactly
how she feels no one knows how Ronda
Rousey feels to be in her position it
was a very unique position to be the
first female face of that sport in such
a big way and I didn't know no GSB John
Jones could even relate to being a woman
and being in the spotlight like
spotlight like she was so I don't think
it was an easy spot and I think it's
easy to [ __ ] on her you know because
she's lost but I think she's you know
mm-hmm I don't think that you should
apologize though for your comments I
think that person's a little bit I'm
sorry you really are yeah her prediction
was correct though
Amanda Nunez I picked yeah I I'm sorry I
maybe it was a little hostile I'm a fan
and please don't come to my life pop sir
please come to our live podcast Rhonda
can come but this guy is finite
we always welcome what okay don't yeah
she can come she can come
[Music]